a lot of these people will likely be
going on that journey of like building a
patch or building a desk or building
expertise you know what i mean what are
the fundamentals of getting that right
and doing it well i'm being successful
do you think the fundamentals if you're
starting out say building a new patch is
you've got to get to know the best
candidates within it so the first thing
you've got to do is get to know all the
top candidates in in the market so by
doing that you're not going to get to
know the companies that people are
working for so you can strip their cv so
say you gotta approach it from day one
you're gonna you want to find out who
the companies are that you can actually
recruit for if you go onto a candidate
in your spaces cv strip that so you get
the one two three four five companies
off it you know those companies hire
what you're about to recruit for before
you know it you've done ten cvs you've
got 50 companies right so they can now
become your target companies you can
speak to these candidates find out who
the hiring managers are in each of those
companies that they've worked at there
you go now you've got 50 hiring managers
that hire say contractors in your area
and by getting keep going and speaking
to candidates identifying who the best
ones are my advice would be to get like
the best ones in each area like my
market now work day
is split up into different areas like
it's the hr side is based upon nine
modules so we would know the
top people that recruit that specialise
in each module
so as soon as a position comes up you
can be very reactive and just go bang
you know here's a cv so yeah yeah you
need to know who the best people are so
as soon as a position comes live you
haven't even got a source for it you've
just got them there can it straight over
move on to the next one so you're
setting up a patch you've got to know
the best candidates are and you've got
to know who your clients are and you've
got to know what projects are going on
within your space pretty quickly so if
you can get on to find out what projects
are going on you can get in on one of
those you're going to get a lot of
contractors in there the recruitment
mentors podcast is proudly sponsored by
vincerie and the award-winning sauce
breaker